Nowadays, index fund investing is one of the
most popular and reliable ways to grow your
wealth over the long term.
And given the high diversification, the low
volatility, and the extreme ease of index
funds, it’s no wonder they’re so popular.
But index funds aren’t a classic investment
tool like you might think.
Just 30 years ago, index funds were largely
avoided, and 50 years ago, index fund investing
wasn’t even a thing.
It wasn’t until 1972 that the world’s
first index fund was created.
Vanguard entered the scene a few years later
in 1975, and since then they’ve grown to
be the king of index funds.
The largest index fund today is actually the
SPDR SPY ETF, but this is more of an anomaly.
If you look right below Spy, you’ll see
that 5 out of the top 10 funds are from Vanguard
and that 31 out of the top 100 funds are also
from Vanguard.
So, here’s how Vanguard became the second
largest investment firm in the world by just
embracing average.
It all started with a man named John C Bogle
who was born on May 8, 1929 right before the
great depression started.
John’s family, unfortunately, got annihilated
by the great depression.
His parents lost all of their savings and
they were forced to sell their house.
John’s father basically gave up on life
and became an alcoholic which resulted in
John’s parents divorcing.
So, from a very young age, John was on his
own and his clearest path to success was education.
John and his twin brother David both worked
extremely hard at school to try to get ahead,
and this would end up paying off.
John’s stellar academic record earned him
a spot at an elite boarding school named Blair
Academy on a full-ride work scholarship.
Today, Blair Academy charges $66,500 per year
and they only have a total of 462 students.
So, I think it’s safe to assume that they
don’t give these spots very easily.
Anyway, John continued to excel at Blair and
he would eventually get accepted into Princeton.
At Princeton, John majored in economics and
investments and it didn’t take him long
to delve into the world of mutual funds.
During his junior and senior years in college,
John wrote a graduating thesis paper called
“The Economic Role of the Investment Company”.
This paper would actually get John his first
job.
The story goes that Walter L Morgan, the founder
of the Wellington fund read John’s 130-page
paper and that he hired John right after.
John quickly became a star at the fund and
by 1955, John was promoted to being an assistant
manager of the fund.
John also pushed for the creation of a new
fund that was less concentrated than Wellington’s
other funds.
Eventually, John would get his way and this
new fund turned out to be a great success.
Soon enough, Walter Morgan would retire from
the company in 1970 and he would choose John
to be his successor.
Things were going phenomenally for John.
He had become the leader of a well-respected
fund at a rather young age of 41 years old.
But, unfortunately, John would make a fateful
decision that would get him ousted from the
company.
In the 1970s, John approved a merger that
turned out to be a disaster, and John would
be fired soon after.
Though this was likely a terrible experience,
what’s surprising is that John never complained
about it or tried to make excuses.
In fact, he describes the mistake as quote
“shameful and inexcusable and a reflection
of immaturity and confidence beyond what the
facts justified.”
It’s crazy how down to earth and humble
John was despite all of his success.
John decided to start his own investment firm
named Vanguard in 1974 and that brings us
to the creation of the index fund.
John is often credited with inventing the
world’s first index fund, but this isn’t
actually the case.
The first idea for an index funds dates back
to two University of Chicago students.
Edward Renshaw and Paul Feldstein suggested
the idea of creating an unmanaged investment
company way back in 1960, but the idea barely
got any support and it didn’t go anywhere.
A decade later though, a company named Qualidex
Fund Inc would make their vision a reality
by creating a fund that tracked the Dow Jones
Industrial Average on July 31, 1972.
So, John was not the first to create an index
fund, but he’s still no doubt the father
of index fund investing given that he was
the one to popularize it.
John launched Vanguard’s first index fund
called the First Index Investment Trust on
December 31, 1975.
The success of Vanguard didn’t just happen
overnight though because there was a massive
problem.
In the 1970s, there was very little respect
for index fund investing within wall street.
Fund managers thought that the idea of index
funds was whimsical and utterly pointless.
It wasn’t just fund managers saying this
either, most investors held a similar belief
due to 2 key reasons.
First of all, investors felt that they could
just do it themselves if they wanted to.
All an index fund is doing is splitting the
money you invest across dozens or hundreds
of companies depending on what the fund is
tracking.
Investors could easily just do that themselves.
They could call up their brokerage and tell
them to split their money across Nasdaq stocks
or S&P 500 stocks.
The investor wouldn’t even have to go through
the tediousness of buying 500 different stocks,
that was the brokerages’ problem.
The second argument against index funds was
that it was quote and quote unamerican and
counterintuitive.
People invest with fund managers to beat the
market, not to match the market.
This is why the chairman of Fidelity Edward
Johnson said that he couldn’t believe that
the great mass of investors would be satisfied
with receiving just average returns.
And these fund managers were right about Vanguard
at least at the start.
The launch of the First Index Investment Trust
was a massive disappointment.
John was hoping to raise $150 million during
the IPO but they only ended up raising a measly
$11 million.
Now, you might be thinking $11 million isn’t
that bad.
But the thing to keep in mind is that Vanguard
is just a manager of assets which means that
they’re only paid a very small percentage
of what they manage.
Even if they charged 1% which is super high
for a passive fund, they would only make $110,000
per year.
And that money isn’t just for John, that
money needs to support the operations of the
entire company.
Fortunately, Vanguard was just a group of
three people including John and two analysts,
so the overhead costs were that large.
Nonetheless, the IPO was extremely disappointing.
The banks that helped John complete the IPO
advised that he should shut down the fund
given the poor reception, but John refused.
John strongly believed that index fund investing
would become more popular for two of his own
reasons.
His first argument was that the fees of an
index fund just had to be low enough for it
to be worth investors’ time.
The S&P 500 adds companies and kicks out companies
on a quarterly basis.
So, if you’re trying to track the S&P 500
on your own, you would have to rebalance your
portfolio every quarter.
Also, every time you wanted to add money in
or take money out of your portfolio, you would
have to buy or sell the stocks of 500 different
companies.
And whether it’s the investor doing it or
the broker doing it on behalf of the investor,
someone has to spend the time and money to
accurately track the desired index.
If you were able to offer this service for
a silly low price, investors and brokers may
very well be interested.
Since the start of Vanguard, one of the key
characteristics has been their stupid low
fees.
The annual fee on their S&P 500 fund VOO for
instance is only 0.03% per year.
This means that for every $10,000 you invest,
Vanguard only charges $3 per year.
I think you can see why this is quite attractive.
John’s second belief was that over the long
term, actively managed funds would lose to
the market.
And over time, we’ve seen that this is indeed
the case with most funds.
But in the late 1970s, John’s low fees and
long-term outlook weren’t very convincing.
At the end of the first year, the index fund
had only grown to $17 million.
But eventually, when the bull market started
in 1982 after the inflation crisis of the
1970s, the indices finally started to grow
at a substantial rate.
This significantly boosted the interest in
index fund investing, but index funds were
still largely avoided.
Something that did help Vanguard though was
the start of the 401k era in the 1908s.
Instead of directly targeting investors and
brokerages with their index funds, Vanguard
switched its focus to companies.
Unlike investors and wall street who were
concerned about beating the market and generating
the greatest returns possible, companies were
more concerned about giving their employees
a low-cost, reliable, and stable investment
option, and index funds were perfect for this.
Vanguard became a top choice for employee
retirement funds and 401k plans which allowed
Vanguard to finally gain some traction.
Vanguard didn’t stop targeting direct investors
either though.
They actually came out with more options for
direct investors.
In December of 1986, Vanguard launched their
second fund which was the Total Bond Fund.
In December of 1987, Vanguard launched the
extended market index fund which tracks the
entire stock market.
Since then, Vanguard has continuously launched
fund after fund each with a different focus
such as small market cap companies and commodities.
All of these new funds combined with the rise
of retirement funds, Vanguard blew up during
the 1980s and they ended the decade with $55.8
billion in assets under management.
For most funds, this would be a fantastic
amount but given Vanguard’s extremely low
fee structure, they needed much more to make
the same amount of money as a regular $55.8
billion funds.
With a 0.03% fee, for instance, Vanguard would
only be pulling in $16.7 million per year
despite managing $55.8 billion.
Fortunately, though, Vanguard’s assets would
continue to grow exponentially throughout
the 1990s.
The key development in the 1990s and early
2000s was the rise of tech companies and the
dot-com bubble.
Tech companies paid their employees extremely
well which made managing their retirements
funds extremely lucrative.
By 2005, Vanguard’s assets under management
grew to just under $1 trillion.
In the meantime, John retired from Vanguard
in 1999 as he reached the mandatory retirement
age at the company of 70.
Since John’s retirement, the new leaders
of Vanguard have placed more focus on actively
managed funds, but ironically, this is when
the popularity of index funds went through
the roof.
In the late 2000s, Warren Buffett made his
famous bet against hedge funds, and retail
investors have been more than happy to take
it easy and simply enjoy market returns.
This newfound retail interest has skyrocketed
Vanguard’s total assets under management
to a whopping $7.5 trillion.
But what I think is even more impressive than
their crazy balance sheet is their ethics.
Wall Street often gets a bad rep for terrible
ethics and most of the criticism they get
is well deserved.
But the same cannot be said about Vanguard.
The only profit Vanguard makes is the measly
fees they charge on their funds.
Now, of course, they manage trillions, so
they make plenty of money.
But what I’m referring to is the fact that
Vanguard doesn’t actually have any investors.
John strongly believed that it was a major
conflict of interest to offer stock in a company
that was meant to generate the best returns
possible for their fund investors.
Every dollar the company makes is one less
dollar that could’ve been paid out to the
fund investors.
So, John decided that Vanguard would have
no ownership whatsoever.
Vanguard doesn’t have any stock and it’s
not privately owned.
Instead, Vanguard likes to say that the company
is owned by all the investors of their funds.
To put in perspective how much Vanguard is
giving up with this decision, let’s take
a look at Blackrock.
Blackrock is the largest asset manager in
the world and they manage over $9 trillion
worth of assets.
Blackrock does have stock and its market cap
is $138 billion.
Even if we said that Vanguard was only valued
half as much as Blackrock, that would be about
$70 billion.
John could’ve easily held onto 25% of the
company which would’ve given him a net worth
of $17.5 billion.
But instead, John died with a net worth of
only $80 million.
Obviously, that’s not a bad amount, but
for someone who literally created trillions
of dollars of value for American investors,
that’s an awfully modest salary.
Something else I wanted to note is that John
gave half of his salary to charity.
Truly quite an inspiring story, but we’ll
have to see how long Vanguard upholds John’s
ethics because John, unfortunately, passed
away 2 years ago in 2019.
I’m sure his legacy with Vanguard, however,
will live on forever.
What do you guys think about Vanguard’s
business model?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if John’s ethics inspire
you.
And of course, consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.